[Applaudissements]
ce qui se passe des choses
jean luc est exactement ce sens nous
allons recevoir les plus grandes stars
du cinéma exactement les plus grandes
stars du cinéma vont se succéder
ici sur le tapis rouge bien sûr deux des
huit
on va accueillir tout de suite la
première star jean luc lemoine alors je
ne sais plus de qui il s'agit on va tout
de suite vous voulez découvrir toutes
fenêtres l'ouvrir voilà il ya beaucoup
de fans qui sont déjà présents oui
attention la voilà
indiana jones
non ces bagnards johnson
des légumes
jones
[Musique]
les passants pouvaient les doigts
c'était bien qu'elle ait concédé avec la
loi parce que ça pète sidonie parce
qu'en fait vous êtes fait mordre par une
loi
absolument j'en ai la preuve hier pour
les gens qui pensaient que je mentais
sur twitter regarder ça on la voit là la
marque ou pas la marque donnera
c'est très impressionnant à l'argent ici
je ne mens jamais dans cette émission
d'accord alors êtes vous avez dit tout
petit moins au tagueur c'est mon
complexe
voilà et celle ci doit en tout cas vous
êtes très beau comme ça fait plaisir
indiana jones et en short bas depuis
qu'ils n'avaient pas de pantalon now à
la pratique on accueille deuxième star
un tapis rouge je vous regarde et c'est
parti
il
à
c'est quand il dit
[Musique]
je vous dis je voulais du doudou le
premier mot qui me vient à l'esprit
classe le dégoût de dégoût et la peine à
elle le dégoût et la peine je vous avez
mis votre temps s'établit cij personnel
ouais ben vous éviterez de mal passer un
jour un jour elle vous ai mis des choses
dans ces baumes à cmpak en amour merci
allez c'est bon sérieusement j'ai pas
d'epo main c'est vrai quoi tout le monde
ne pas manger de porc
allez je crois que c'est chez les bons
karim zéribi
plus que la bagarre c'est pas possible
pas ses mots thierry maugez des grillons
cécile minibus
l'upi la casse et c'est bon c'est bon
viala et laisser téléguider de la raison
tu es déguisant cécile de ménibus c'est
l'aval de jean luc azoulay pas la mienne
vous le dépôt d'une gerbe aujourd'hui et
non mais lemoine du faubourg
saint-antoine
allez c'est bon allez vas-y ces bombes a
fait valoir me fait peur c'est quoi les
vannes n'avait pas compris hanouna du
pilat casser le médoc lemoine du
faubourg-saint-antoine oui ça n'allait
pas mieux
non j'ai rien compris la vanne moi non
plus bon allez partout dans la tristesse
oui
un jour en jour
[Musique]
je sais pas si mes soirées où l'on dira
médicaments ont des râles teletubbies
merci merci à l'inversé c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-luc vous pouvez dire en quoi il est
déguisé donc qui les déguisant mylène
farmer dans libertines tinios le
seclinois oui ah oui nous croquons mur
de huy est ok ce pays qui reste à
l'achat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la bouche d'aération
m
alors
c'est bien lionel ségard
qu'avez-vous fait pour son client je
croyais pas mais non mais j'étais étonné
qu est-ce qu à celle achète par le
public ce qu'elle aime bien très bas par
marilyn monroe très bien vous allez
faire toutes les belles choses comme ça
oui je la sens bien génériques et on se
retrouve tous deux souhaité partir et
vêtements